yeah
when anna and john found out she was
pregnant with elias there was joy hope
but also fear
their first three pregnancies had ended
with miscarriages they couldn't bear to
think of it happening again you don't
expect it to be such a
heart-wrenching thing i guess because in
many ways it's just a very medical
experience you know they don't talk
about it as a baby they talk about it as
a fetus and
you know it's surgery and drugs and
hospitals and there's no kind of
consideration that
to me that that's a tiny human
and that's a tiny human that was going
to come into my life
and now they're gone um and you know
they're never gonna come back
but each time anna felt pressure to get
back to the office the biggest mistakes
that we made with those miscarriages was
um me going back to work
so soon and
it really dragged out the grief for me
so i was grieving for months whereas if
there was a specific leave made for if
you've gone through a miscarriage then
it gives you permission i think to take
it and i think that's really important
it's estimated that as many as one in
four pregnancies ends in miscarriage but
one survey found over a third of
employees didn't know their rights
currently there's no statutory
entitlement to paid leave for people who
lose a baby before 24 weeks of pregnancy
mp angela crawley wants to change that
with a bill to entitle all parents to
paid miscarriage leave i believe it is
for the uk government like
new zealand and like the scottish
government who have introduced three
days paid leave in the public sector and
made that commitment to their public
sector employees that the uk government
could look to do the same my bill would
be primarily to seek dj's paid leave for
parents before 24 weeks and campaigners
want businesses to offer more support
the bottom line is
that you would hope that all employers
want the best for their workforce
but even if they might not have you know
the warm and fuzzy values that that we
wish all employers did
it makes good business sense
in in every way to take care of your
workforce the government says it's
urging employers to show compassion and
flexibility but many feel the rights of
parents don't go far enough
cheers becky johnson sky news derbyshire